alright I've already seen the movie
attacked the block now we have attacked
the intelligence of the audience with
aliens I'm tired that's the best intro I
got there's nothing more to say the
watch so the watch stars Ben Stiller
Jonah Hill Vince Vaughn and this one
date I don't really know that much about
he's pretty funny and Ben Stiller's the
manager of a Costco and then a guy gets
slaughtered in his Costco so he's like
I'm gonna form a neighborhood watch
consisting of him Vince Vaughn Jonah
Hill and that one dude I don't know that
much about and now they're a
neighborhood watch keeping the
neighborhood safe from scum and
apparently aliens but not bad movies
right I feel like I'm gonna be a little
hard on this movie it's not because I'm
still thinking Dark Knight Rises it's
just because the watch was all over the
place but sometimes it was funny
sometimes it was raunchy sometimes it
was really lowbrow humor that made you
want to shoot yourself in the face and
it had funny dialogue again sometimes
the characters are funny sometimes
they're a little crazy sometimes they're
just downright creepy cuz it's like
alright we're just gonna make a movie
that's gonna come out a week after the
Dark Knight Rises just throw it up the
screen no one needs to want to see the
movie they're just gonna have to see the
movie when Dark Knight Rises is still
sold out and I just have to go to
something else and they'll go to the
lodge a week after Dark Knight Rises is
where movies go to die yes it's a good
marketing tactic and yeah the whole
thing in the wash is they find out oh
shoot there's aliens that are in the
neighborhood so they got to take those
on too and that could be actually really
cool I'll say everyone has their shot at
funny Vince Vaughn has funny moments
Jonah Hill has funny moments that dude I
don't know that much about who's pretty
funny has his funny moments Ben Stiller
has his funny moments but in the end the
movie was just so jumbled and everywhere
it was all over the place it's like
someone took the movie attacked the
block put it in the microwave turned it
on high it exploded and it just became a
sloppy ass mess he recognized all the
elements but come on you can't eat it
now that's what the watch is it has a
couple twists in the movie and like
halfway through you're like I know the
twist that's gonna be a twist and that's
gonna be a twist done and I was right I
was disappointed that I was right you
shouldn't be able to guess it that
easily I mean Ted is a comedy it's still
in theaters and it's a hundred times
funnier than this movie when I came out
of the movie I told someone this I was
like you got to admit Larry the Cable
Guy could have been cast as a lead in
this movie and it would have made
perfect sense and it's completely true
it's like a Larry the Cable Guy movie
without Larry the Cable Guy in
in the end I will say the watch is okay
but you're not going to remember in
t-minus one day yep already forgot I
wanted to like it I chuckled in a couple
parts but just didn't do it for me
however if you're still in the Dark
Knight Rises me like a lot of people are
I did a podcast with schmoes know we
talk about all things Dark Knight Rises
complete spoiler I put a link to the
podcast below check it out it's a lot
more entertaining than this movie so if
you're thinking of watching the watch
down stay at home listen to the podcast
to be modest I see your favorite Vince
Vaughn movie that's gonna be the
question today what is it comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more